bonjour Béatrice Gosselin bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous accompagner pendant
cette première demi-heure on est ravi de
vous recevoir pour la première fois dans
cette émission merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes élu de la
Manche à parenté au groupe les
républicains montent de la commission de
la culture et de l'éducation et avant de
parler du texte dont vous êtes la
rapporteur justement un mot puisque vous
êtes une ancienne professeur des écoles
les concours d'enseignants ne font pas
le plein cette année dans certaines
disciplines et certaines académies il y
a plus il y a moins de candidats
admissibles que de post proposer est-ce
qu'on va vers une aggravation de la
pénurie de professeurs j'ose espérer que
non mais il est vrai que les indices
sont plutôt dramatiques à ce sujet et ça
fait quelques années que les le nombre
de postulants et est faible et on ne
n'arrive pas à compléter on a donc a eu
affaire les dernières ces dernières
années ces dernières années à une
formation de quatre jours pour des
enseignants mais c'est une c'est quelque
chose qui ne peut pas durer parce que ça
ça n'est pas du tout du tout
convaincant puisque des gens arrêtent au
bout de au bout de quelques semaines et
n'ayant pas un effectif suffisant on
prend les remplaçants qui eux se
trouvent sur des postes fixes et quand
des gens sont en congé maladie ou en
formation les postes ne sont pas
remplacés donc on a vraiment une pénurie
dans une professeur des écoles comme de
professeurs de façon générale au lycée
collège et il faut vraiment que cette
cette hémorragie arrête comment vous
l'expliquez cette pénurie cette crise
d'évocation finalement tout à fait et
c'est vous l'avez dit c'est une crise
évocation je crois que ce métier qui
intéresse beaucoup d'enseignants puisque
moi quand j'ai fait ma formation nous
étions nombreux à postuler et peu et peu
d'élus et bien c'est l'effet inverse
maintenant et il est vrai que que c'est
un gros problème je crois que la
le salaire mais pas que puisqu'il y a eu
des efforts de fait mais je crois qu'il
y a aussi toute une toute une révision
un petit peu du du rôle de l'enseignant
de l'image de l'enseignant par rapport
aux familles aussi et par rapport à aux
institutions je crois qu'il y a vraiment
peu de considérations oui peu de
considération
je crois que l'autorité de l'enseignant
et mise à mal et que et que les
enseignants ne s'y retrouvent pas ils
ont un métier ils ont été formés pour
sauf dans les dernières années pour
certains mais je crois qu'il faut leur
faire confiance ce manque de formation
oui ça joue parce que parce que c'est
vrai que on ne peut pas être c'est déjà
un métier où on apprend sur le tas je
peux vous l'affirmer si on n'a pas un
minimum de base et de formation et puis
d'intérêt aussi c'est pas un métier
comprend par défaut parce que il y a des
gens personne qui font des études et
puis ne sachant pas trop où aller choisi
ce métier en disant ben je vais voir
mais c'est un métier qu'on choisit et
qu'on choisit parce que c'est comme
beaucoup de professions qui sont auprès
de l'humain comme le monde de médical au
niveau des infirmiers et des médecins
c'est un monde où on a des relations on
a on a vraiment besoin de cet échange
avec les avec les élèves et avec les
enfants et je crois que cette amitié
qu'on choisit et quand c'est par défaut
ou quand c'est une une idée comme ça ça
ne peut pas tenir
on va parler de votre texte
d'un projet de loi examiner aujourd'hui
sur la restitution des biens culturels
spolié pendant la période nazie on va
voir d'abord les détails de ce texte
avec notre journaliste Alexandre tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Béatrice Gosselin bonjour et
Alex ce projet de loi va donc permettre
de restituer plus facilement les biens
culturels qui ont été spolies aux Juifs
durant la période nazie effectivement on
estime à 100 000 le nombre de biens
culturels qui ont été spoliés entre 1933
et 1945 en France dans le cadre de
persécution antisémite parmi ces œuvres
et bien 60 000 ont été retrouvés en
Allemagne et renvoyés en France 45 000
ont été restitués à leur propriétaire ou
à leurs ayant droit 2200 ont été
conservés à la garde des musées
nationaux en attente de trouver leur
propriétaire et puis 13000 oeuvres ont
été vendues par l'État et donc beaucoup
d'oeuvres se retrouvent sur le marché de
l'art il a donc un travail important à
faire pour retrouver ses oeuvres spolier
et ensuite les restituer et d'autant que
juridiquement Alex c'est assez compliqué
pour restituer ses œuvres culturelles
spolier
certaines sont dans des collections
nationales publiques elles sont
protégées déclarées inaliénables et donc
il est difficile
typiquement de les restituer alors
actuellement il y a deux voies pour
procéder assez restitutions soit et bien
il faut faire une loi spécifique ça a
été le cas l'an dernier pour restituer
une quinzaine d'oeuvres et notamment le
tableau de Gustave climt Le Roseau sous
les arbres un seul Clint appartenant à
la France il a été restitué aux ayants
droits de sa propriétaire autrichienne
qui a été victime de l'Holocauste et
puis le deuxième moyen de restitution
c'est tout simplement une décision de
justice donc actuellement ça prend du
temps et le gouvernement veut accélérer
cette procédure de restitution avec ce
projet de loi ce texte permettra à
l'état par décret de déroger au principe
d'inan d'inaliénabilité voilà j'ai
réussi voilà un principe pour ses œuvres
de collection publique alors une
dérogation après avis d'une commission
spécialisée et donc ensuite la
restitution de l'oeuvre spolier sera
possible ce projet de loi il permet
également au musée privé qui sont agréés
par l'État de pouvoir procéder assez
restitution donc c'est un texte qui fait
plutôt consensus au Parlement qui est
d'ailleurs a été inspiré par des travaux
de sénateurs Béatrice Gosselin ce projet
de loi il va marquer une étape dans ce
long processus de restitution de ces
œuvres spolier oui il vise à donner une
impulsion importante au processus de
réparation des préjudices commis pendant
la période de 39-45
et vous l'avez dit ce texte est vise
principalement les oeuvres qui sera dans
les musées dans les collections des
musées et qui ne peuvent sortir sans ces
projets de loi qu'il a comme celui du 21
février 2022 et qui qui nous a qui donc
a permis de ressortir 16 16 œuvres de de
bien qui était dans ses musées et qui
est appartenait à des familles spoliées
donc cette loi permettra de ne plus
passer par cette cette navette
législative parlementaire elle elle
c'est une loi cadre qui est proposée
donc par le par le gouvernement et qui
permettra après la vie de la Commission
de la CIVS qui est la commission
d'indemnisation des victimes spoliées de
victimes de spoliation et bien pourra la
collectivité choisira de rendre ou de ne
pas rendre l'oeuvre aux ayants droits
pourquoi vous avez choisi de travailler
sur ce sujet d'être apporteur de ce
texte écoutez ce texte quand on m'a
proposé ma particulièrement intéressé et
il y a une valeur je trouve qu'il y a il
a il a ressenti important sur le plan de
de la de l'émotion c'est vrai que on le
voit à chaque fois que qu'il est
présenté l'importance pour les pour les
ayants droits pour les familles spolier
le le l'envie d'avoir cette réparation
et et je pense la nécessité de la France
et d'autres pays de faire cette
réparation qui auprès de 80 ans et il me
semble indispensable et nécessaire un
mot sur la date puisque vous le
rappeliez ça concerne la période 33-45
la France n'a été occupée à partir de
juin 40 il y a eu des spoliations avant
oui tout à fait il y avait déjà des des
actes de spoliation alors sans doute
beaucoup moins important que pendant la
période de l'Occupation et du
gouvernement de Vichy mais il y avait
déjà des actes donc on a on a vraiment
fait large au niveau de l'espace de de
l'arrivée
mais aussi par rapport au pays parce que
le texte de le texte de la comment
l'ordonnance de 1945 permettait sur le
plan judiciaire de redonner des biens
poliers en France pendant la période de
la période de l'occupation donc ça nous
a permis d'élargir le spectre et de et
de de d'agir sur plusieurs périodes qui
n'étaient pas prises en compte
auparavant donc c'est une élargissement
important alors vous le disiez ce texte
va faciliter le travail de réparation
mais ça permet aussi un travail de
mémoire vis-à-vis de ces familles
spolier qui ont été victimes de ces
persécutions antisémites tout à fait et
ce travail de mémoire est indispensable
parce que pour certaines familles après
les conditions que nous ayons nous ayons
pu faites c'est l'important c'est
parfois la comment la valeur de l'oeuvre
mais c'est aussi le sens de cette
réparation de ce travail de mémoire et
de la reconnaissance de de des actes
innommable qui ont pu avoir lieu pendant
cette période de trouble qu'est-ce qui
ressort justement de ces auditions de
préparation au débat de ce projet de loi
et de ses familles qui ont été spolié
elle raconte un long combat pour
retrouver ses oeuvres et avoir
réparation c'est parfois très long c'est
parfois très complexe et ça va le
devenir de plus en plus au fil des
générations qui passent et et mais je
crois que au moins que les travaux
soient faits pour les recherches de
provenance et permettre aux gens aux
personnes de dire oui il y a réellement
eu un acte de spoliation et je crois que
c'est ce que les victimes veulent
entendre les familles des victimes
veulent entendre que que leurs ancêtres
leur grand-père arrière-grand-père ont
été victimes de ces de ces de ces gestes
totalement délictueux car si on regarde
les chiffres en est en 2023 l'estimation
c'est à peu près 100 000 oeuvres qui
auraient été spolié au final
actuellement et bien environ 50000 ont
été restitués c'est voilà il manque
quand même la moitié ça paraît colossal
80 ans après oui tout à fait mais vous
parlez d'oeuvre d'art mais le projet de
loi de la loi cadre aussi beaucoup plus
de faces puisqu'il englobe bien sûr les
objets d'art mais aussi le mobilier les
livres et tout et les instruments de
musique qui sont des objets beaucoup
plus difficiles à retracer parce que en
plusieurs exemplaires et parfois on nous
n'avons pas le nom du propriétaire donc
il est parfois très compliqué de
retrouver mais c'est donc ça s'est
ouvert aussi sur l'ensemble des objets
qui est sont concernés donc je crois que
bien sûr il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'objets d'art mais il n'y a pas que et
il faut continuer dès qu'on le peut à
remonter les chevaux pour retrouver les
les l'origine et le tracé de cette œuvre
la première loi de restitution était
adoptée il y a un an et demi c'est très
récent celle-là vient compléter
l'arsenal juridique pourquoi si tard
pourquoi si tard alors c'est vrai que
jusqu'en 1950 il y a eu beaucoup de vous
l'avez dit beaucoup d'oeuvres de
restituer aux familles dès que ça a été
possible et les choses ont été fait un
blog après il y a eu vraisemblablement
peut-être pas une volonté d'oubli mais
de passer à autre chose alors et vrai
pour le gouvernements c'était vrai aussi
pour les conservateurs du musée qui
parfois se disaient on a des collections
c'est compliqué de s'en séparer on est
responsables de nos collections et puis
je crois aussi qu'il a fallu du temps
pour les familles des victimes parce que
les premiers première générations ont
été peut-être dans le dans un besoin
plus urgent et puis petit à petit au fil
des années peut-être pas la volonté non
plus c'était peut-être trop compliqué
mais mentalement et psychologiquement de
de faire ses recherches et puis au bout
de certaines de quelques générations la
deuxième troisième surtout la troisième
génération ce besoin de se retourner
vers le passé peut-être un petit peu
moins
d'affection proche enfin de sensibilité
exacerbée et normale je ne mets pas du
tout et un besoin de dire oui et bien il
est temps qu'on fasse cette réparation
je crois que le temps à mis ça et puis
il y a eu les accords de Washington il y
a eu ensuite le discours de Jacques
Chirac le rapport à partir de Jacques
Chirac que politiquement les choses ont
évolué vous parliez de sénateurs et
Madame bouchou a longuement travaillé
sur ce sujet des
années 90 et je crois que que c'était
elle le point de départ de cette volonté
de remettre en action de remettre en
oui en action et de d'apporter ce
dynamisme même si on aimerait qu'il
aille encore plus vite et plus longtemps
est-ce que du coup cette loi ça aussi
pour but de sensibiliser le monde de la
culture à cette question de la rustique
alors je crois que le monde de la
culture a pris conscience des problèmes
c'était je vous dis les premières
générations de conservateur était
peut-être moins orientées maintenant ils
sont une formation pour cela et puis ils
se rendent compte et je crois qu'on a
tous évolué aussi que l'important est de
réparer et de faire ce travail de
mémoire et je pense et pour l'avoir vu
dans les 16 œuvres qui sont qui ont été
recyclées l'an dernier je crois que
aucun des musées n'a souhaité passer à
autre chose n'a souhaité mettre en cause
la restitution ça a été vraiment une
décision unanime de l'ensemble des
musées concernés vous avez aussi tenu à
ce que les musées privés
pour quelle raison parce que dans les
musées préférés privés il y a aussi ses
œuvres et les musées privés ont aussi
ont des biens incessibles sauf pour les
transmettre d'amuser à l'autre donc le
fait de d'adopter cette loi cadre de la
d'avoir par dérogation aussi la
possibilité de le faire dans les musées
leur permet d'avoir le même processus
que les musées publiques je crois que
c'est important que l'ensemble des
musées qui ont ces collections dans
lesquelles il peut y avoir des objets
spolier puisse avoir ses démarches une
des innovations de ce texte c'est aussi
la possibilité pour les parties de
conclure un accord à l'amiable sur
d'autres modalités que la restitution
comment ça va marcher ça alors d'abord
la CIVS donne un avis donc ensuite la
plupart du temps les collectivités
suivent cet avis après c'est le choix
vraiment de la collectivité ou du musée
et puis et derrière on peut proposer un
rapport les deux parties se mettent
autour d'une table et décident en commun
accord et là c'est vraiment un accord
tacite de restituer l'oeuvre où au
contraire si elle appartient dans un
dans une collection ou
que les héritiers souhaitent plutôt la
laisser dans le cadre cette collection
et bien de dire on la laisse au musée
alors moyennant une compensation
financière ou peut-être une autre forme
de Me de mémoire tout simplement une une
proposition de la mettre en valeur de
marque et l'historique de cette œuvre le
la difficulté et le musée labanche qui a
eu une tapisserie a été un peu
innovateur puisque la question a été
posée le propriétaire spolié allemand a
choisi de la laisser dans la collection
et finalement ça a peut-être été le
déclencheur de cette de cette de ce
processus qui permet plusieurs modalités
et je trouve que c'est important mais ça
pose aussi la question de
des moyens des collectivités
territoriales Alex après elle va parler
des moyens de recherche mais sur les
moyens des collectivités territoriales
est-ce qu'elles ont toujours les moyens
de garder ses œuvres ou est-ce qu'il
faut que l'État les aide alors justement
c'était la question et c'est un des
points sur lequel je vais je vais
interroger le gouvernement parce que il
est évident que certains musées
notamment le musée la de
Brive-la-Gaillarde qui a eu cette ce
processus et bien c'était deux années de
leur budget qu'ils ont mis en avant pour
pour payer l'indemnisation la
compensation financière et c'est n'est
pas facile d'être forcément donc là ils
ont réussi à trouver les fonds ils en
sont ravis mais c'est vrai que là l'État
français sera peut-être à se poser la
question de savoir si l'État ne doit pas
intervenir puisque ce ne sont pas
forcément les musées qui sont concernés
mais c'est le problème de l'état de
l'état du gouvernement de Vichy qui
était qui était qui a posé ses
difficultés donc je crois qu'il faut
vraiment que cette question soit posée
au gouvernement et que l'on ait les
réponses de la part du gouvernement et
du ministre de la Culture est-ce que
l'État doit mettre des moyens
supplémentaires pour rechercher
retrouver les oeuvres spoliées restantes
également les ayants droits alors je
crois réellement que c'est aussi la
deuxième interrogation c'est à dire et
bien il faut avancer dans ce processus
et aller plus vite et cette voie 4 nous
le permettra mais si nous nous en
donnons pas les moyens les grands musées
nationaux Parisiens ont quelques moyens
des petits musées de territoires qui ont
parfois déjà du mal à avoir du personnel
suffisant pour les pour le l'accueil etc
et donc là c'est un travail monumental
de recherche et tous ne l'ont pas la
CIVS il y a des moyens il y a des
parfois des des aides au niveau ponctuel
mais pourquoi pas trouver des moyens qui
puissent être mutualisés etc mais je
crois réellement que les moyens
financiers les moyens humains doivent
être mis aussi en face pour que cette ce
travail de recherche et de recherche de
provenance avance sinon ça sera sans
doute une belle loi mais qui n'aura pas
lieu d'être puisqu'elle n'aura pas de
elle ne sera pas appliquée dans la
mesure où on n'aura pas fait ses
recherches de provenance je crois qu'il
faut vraiment que ce travail aille de
pair avec tous les moyens financiers et
humains qu'il faut ajouter vous êtes
optimiste là-dessus vous avez des
craintes des inquiétudes moi je crois
qu'il faut être optimiste quoi qu'il en
soit puisqu'il y a quand même il faut le
dire une grande avancée entre ce qui
s'est passé avant 2000 et maintenant
donc je crois qu'il faut être optimiste
maintenant puisque la machine est
enclenchée il faut continuer à la faire
fonctionner merci Alex à tout à l'heure
on parlera de la lutte les violences
faites aux élus exactement ce sera la
suite dans le club et on suivra
évidemment l'examen de ce texte dont
vous êtes là rapporteur aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat on va continuer
avec vous battre est-ce que on va voir
l'actualité dans votre département de la
Manche on va à Saint-Lô retrouvez
Édouard fremy bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous rédacteurs en chef
adjoint de la Manche Libre et doit tout
autre sujet dont on va parler avec vous
on va parler du recul du trait de côte
c'est un grand sujet d'inquiétude dans
la Manche oui oui
le trait de côte c'est le très qu'on
dessine sur la carte et qui marque la
côte et la manche qui est un département
assez préservé on n'a pas beaucoup
bétonné le littoral de la Manche c'est
pour ça qu'il est très beau et bien il y
a la mer il y a la dune et puis derrière
la dune il y a tout simplement les
habitats et les entreprises or la côte
depuis des décennies reculent recul de
plusieurs centaines de mètres on a déjà
des maisons qui ont disparu qui ont été
engloutis par les eaux à l'image vous
voyez une lune que nous avions faites il
y a deux ans puisque on a aussi le parc
naturel régional des Marais du Cotentin
et du bassin qui est pour partie sous le
niveau de la mer donc si la mer monte
peut-être que les digues n'y suffiront
plus et que le Cotentin pourrait devenir
une île alors on a des maisons qui ont
disparu on a des maisons qui qui sont
aujourd'hui menacés directement à chaque
grande marée à Gouville-sur-Mer la
commune de Beth Gosselin dont elle a été
maire il y a un camping qui est un allé
quoi 4 5 6 7 mètres de la mer qui est
directement menacée par la montée des
eaux la montée des eaux donc cette
apparition de zone submersible elle est
immédiatement que ça se passe c'est pas
demain il y a un danger qui est immédiat
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on commence à
parler de déménagement de déplacement de
relocalisation de la population dans des
zones plus arrière il y a des réunions
il y a des déclarations mais il y a pas
beaucoup plus que ça à ma question à
betris Gosselin c'est est-ce que vous y
croyez est-ce que nous allons vraiment
déplacer degrés ou de force des manchois
qui vivent sur le littoral
oui bonjour monsieur Frémy et bien
écoutez oui nous nous avons évidemment
cette difficulté du trait de côte et de
l'érosion puisque vous l'avez dit nos
325 km de côte ne sont pas sans risque
avec la trait du territoire mais aussi
les difficultés de l'érosion qui sont
très importantes dans des territoires du
nerf comme le nôtre puisque nous avons
vous l'avez précisé nous avons deux
campings qui sont en bordure de mer et
qu'il a fallu
sur lequel j'ai été vraiment très
investi puisque c'était le gros la
grosse difficulté c'était ça fait une
dizaine d'années mais les l'année 2020 a
été particulièrement difficile à passer
pour des problèmes de d'érosion
importante et nous avons protégé parce
qu'il fallait protéger les campings pour
ne pas perdre ses structures et puis il
y avait aussi la zone ostréicole
derrière et le poste de secours mais il
est nous avons nous avons ouvert avec
dans le cadre de la communauté de
communes et des trois communes
partenaires puisque nous avons regroupé
un petit peu les difficultés que nous
avions sur les trois communes qui
entourent Gouville enfin les deux
communes BL il écoute en ville et bien
oui effectivement cette comment dire
c'est les expédiants qui ont été pris
dans l'urgence si on raisonne à long
terme mais je crois que Elisabeth borne
qui était premier ministre déjà était
venu sur votre commune dire que voilà il
fallait sur le long terme commencer à
penser des choses puisque on ne déplace
pas la population les entreprises du
jour au lendemain quand la mère quand la
mer arrive donc on en parle mais il y a
pas beaucoup de choses qui bougent il y
a pas de véhicule juridique il y a pas
de montant qui est donné pour les
indemnités qui va payer qui va payer la
la l'indemnité de gens qui vont devoir
abandonner leur maison et puis où est-ce
qu'on va les replacer avec les
difficultés les tensions qu'on connaît
sur les zones constructibles alors j'y
arrivais monsieur le président
nous avons donc avec la communauté de
communes Coutances mere bocage et les
communes concernées mis en place un PPA
c'est-à-dire un projet partenariat
d'aménagement il y en a un dans la
Manche il y en a deux autres à Lacanau
et Saint-Jean-de-Luz pour les
territoires littoraux et ce projet
partenariat d'aménagement a mis tous les
gens autour de la table les services de
l'État
il y a eu donc une convention avec
l'État et donc ne sont partis maintenant
des projets de phase donc la première
partie vous l'avez dit la protection
c'était dans l'urgence mais là nous
avons nous avons un travail avec les
partenaires économiques les partenaires
concernés puisqu'il y a un camping privé
un camping public et puis et puis les
différents services de l'État les
services d'urbanisme pour voir comment
relocaliser ces deux structures de
d'hôtellerie plein air et comment les
remettre et là les interrogations c'est
les finances il y a déjà quelques il y a
un million d'euros de prévu pour les
études parce qu'il y a vraiment un
travail d'étude il y a aussi 5 millions
d'euros de
de fichiers pour voir un petit peu
comment commencer à voir à organiser et
puis il y a maintenant un problème au
niveau urbanisme où trouver les terrains
de relocalisation et comment ajouter les
infrastructures et les activités
économiques comment les comment les
faire du perdurer dans le dans le temps
même s'il faut les déplacer et là je
vous rejoins c'est un travail qui va
être de longue haleine mais on a
commencé et c'est déjà bien engagé alors
moi ce que je vois c'est que on était
encore en réunion hier ce sont des
choses qui avance mais ça demande du
temps et puis l'interrogation c'est de
savoir si c'est les terrains qu'on va
renaturer quand on a délocalisé
qu'est-ce que on ne pourra ne pas
compter les terrains qu'on va utiliser
dans l'enveloppe foncière qui nous sera
imparti parce que c'est le problème du
zan et c'est important et de zéro
artificialisation nette et aussi les
contraintes de la loi littorale est-ce
que on a ces dérogations qui seront
nécessaires pour pouvoir à faire nos
aménagements futurs
qui sont directement menacés par la
montée des eaux on insiste encore à des
permis de construire qui sont des
livrets à des zones d'activité
économiques qui sont qui sont déployés
c'est ça qui est paradoxal c'est que
d'un certain côté on a conscience un
danger de l'autre on continue est-ce que
Madame Gosselin vous avez un horizon
vous disiez que que ça que ça prendrait
du temps évidemment mais est-ce que vous
avez un horizon est-ce qu'on sait que si
dans 5 ans dans 10 ans les premiers
déménagements les premières
relocalisations les premières
indemnisations de d'habitants expropriés
pourront avoir lieu est-ce qu'on a un
délai alors on a un délai en ce qui
concerne les localisation de camping on
part sur 5 5 bonnes années je pense pour
le reste ce sont des phasages on peut
pas tout faire en même temps donc c'est
vrai qu'on commence par les endroits les
plus les plus risques les plus à risque
on va évoluer ensuite sur les autres
parties mais je crois que il y a
vraiment une volonté d'avancer après
maintenant quel est l'instrument et
l'outil financier qui pourra se mettre
en place je crois que là il y a encore
des choses à faire puisque est-ce que
c'est l'ensemble de la collectivité
est-ce que c'est au niveau de l'État
est-ce que son niveau de la région ce
qu'on dit au département il y a encore
des choses à mettre en place mais je
crois qu'on avance
c'est pas qu'il va payer c'est les
collectivités locales le département de
la Manche la région où c'est l'état
alors l'État a déjà mis en place une
certaine somme d'argent mais ça ne sera
pas pour la relocalisation en tant que
tel ça ne fera pas tout les
collectivités qu'elle soit commune ou
collectivités communautaire ont mis
aussi de l'argent le département nous
aide aussi pour d'autres avec d'autres
d'autres qui ne sont pas des
financements pour le moment mais
d'autres aides de structure donc on va
on va trouver des solutions je ne vous
dis pas que tout est trouvé loin de là
mais ça avance je ne vous aurais pas dit
ça il y a trois ans donc vous voyez que
l'évolution elle arrive alors par contre
là où je ne suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vous c'est que les
constructions alors peut-être dans
certains territoires mais dans ce
contrat dans le mien les constructions
au bord de mer sont quand même des
choses qui n'existent plus et les zones
qui se mettent en bord de mer maintenant
sont des zones qui sont ostréicoles et
qui sont pas voués tellement éloignées
du du domaine maritime puisqu'il leur
faut de l'eau de mer et il faut aussi
des déplacements pour aller vers les
parcs à huîtres
merci merci d'être Rémi d'avoir été avec
nous la une de la Manche Libre cette
semaine c'est Roland-Garros qui commence
dimanche la Manche à Roland-Garros c'est
à la Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
Édouard frémi d'avoir été avec nous et
merci Béatrice Gosselin d'avoir été
notre invité dans cette émission merci
beaucoup bonne journée à vous dans 20
minutes dans le club des territoires on
parlera des violences subis par les élus
la démission du maire de Saint-Brevin
était un déclencheur dans le débat
public on en parle d'abord on accueille
notre prochaine invité leur la